they're live or in front of a thousand
people. It really makes no difference to
me. I mean, yeah, we're live, right?
We're now we're live and you see the
amount of stupid stuff I go through on
stream. It's like I still get stuff done
and the results are very good, right?
Yeah. So, anyways, welcome. We are uh
we're live now. Let's do be taking a
look at GPU drive stuff. Spencer here.
Um okay. Why don't you send me over the
latest stuff and we will take a
look. I also think I fixed sweeps uh in
the brief period after after those
calls. So hopefully we actually have
that stuff working
again pretty
good. All right. Uh, let me go ahead and
drop you a recent link. And it looks
like it's kind of doing [ __ ] So, all
right.
Okay. The episode return is weird, but
the scorecard is going up. So, we'll see
if that's just a matter of my login
weird.
This one you just linked
or what? All right, here we go.
642 1B.
Yeah, that one. This one.
Um, hold up. Let me put up your stream
on my screen so I can see what you're
looking at.
Oh, yeah. That's way better. Cool.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. See, it's do
it's doing things. Is this with
collisions on or not? What is this? This
is with collisions on. Weirdly enough,
with collisions off, it can't learn
anything.
Huh.
Interesting. Because all it does, it
just respawns back in where it starts.
And it's like, what? What the [ __ ] just
happened to me?
It should still be able to learn stuff
from that if it's getting the collision
reward. But that's weird. Yeah. Yeah, I
mean the collision reward to be getting
is zero if it's if you set it the
penalty zero, but Oh, I see. But it it
respawns and it doesn't get a reward and
it doesn't know like why like So then
yeah, that actually makes sense then.
Oh, great universe. Why did I just get
located to a random place? Yep, that's
fine. So, uh I mean this then is better
than we had before without collision but
with collisions, right?
This
is right now for sure better than before
without
collisions and especially in terms of
like speed because we had a speed issue,
right? Um the off-road rate is probably
some of the best I have this far. Now
the true test is to see whether this
actually eval. So that's yet to be
determined. It still has another two
minutes to go on this run. Okay. I mean,
and also sometimes if it if it dips
towards the end, uh, cosign and nailing,
there's um there's some stuff I need to
look at with that. I don't think I'm
doing it right.
Uh, one thing that's for sure weird that
I've noticed after running longer
experiments is it is almost a guarantee
that if you get to around like 500
million steps, the entropy just does
some weird stuff.
like it'll just like drop like a rock
and then your policy will start doing
weird things and then it'll like try and
recover entropy again and then it'll
like go back to learning again.
Yeah, that's so I don't know what's up
with that. I don't know either. It is
something that I've
noticed. All right. So, uh we got
entropy, we got
score,
and I mean we'll see which of these
don't work. Is this all already after
filtering or no?
Like they had a they had filtering stuff
for like invalid cars and goals and
stuff, didn't they?
Yeah. So, this has a a decent amount of
that in terms of like a bunch of cleanup
on the maps. But, weirdly enough, even
after all the
cleanup, they so they did some cleanup
on the levels that I downloaded, right?
But even with post their cleanup, I have
some cleanup after that. and it's still
not perfectly clean. So, I was trying to
set up
um their original actual just GPU drive
project, but funny enough because I like
I just bought the new box. Um it's not
compatible because CUDA that's um on 124
and that's funny can only use 129 CUDA
or whatever without 128. Yeah, that's
funny.
So, I wanted to look at the I wanted if
you could do that, that would be really
helpful is if you could pull up a map
that can render on their end because
that's the one thing that I'd be trippy
about because my end was still showing
that if you run through the expert
trajectories Mhm. there's still
collisions in off-road, but it should be
zero because otherwise your optimal
trajectory has [ __ ] going on.
Yeah.
Um,
well that's funny.
Do they not have like they don't have
like onload filtering? They don't have
like any like runtime other shenanigans.
Um, I mean from what I've seen I mean
I've asked them quite a few questions on
the subject of it and you know it seems
like they I have reviewed it that they
are doing a good amount of filtering and
cleaning up ahead of it. Mhm. Um, and I
just added one of the things that was
not the same where I subtract the mean
to all the
positions and I was seeing if that did
anything with learning, but it turns out
that's just a camera trick so that all
the maps origin stays at zero.
Um, okay. So, it just finished. It got
93% score. Let me see what happens if I
try and eval the map.
Should be able to like see some cool
stuff happening, right?
You would think so at 90 something%.
It should be at least like decent.
Eval for this is really annoying though
I have to say because of the way I've
set it up
um of the fact that like each env in it
is an independent
map. When you do roll out you can only
roll out one map.
So the way that we do it that I do it by
default with all the M's is we just
render the first one and call it a day.
Sure. And I mean like that's fine, but
like it'd be nice if on this it would
for specifically this type of thing
whenever it's running you can like have
it jump to another map.
Yeah, you can do that potentially. You'd
have to add the key binds.
All right. Actually, that's that's all
you'd have to do is add the key binds
and you could just tap over maps.
Well, no, because you have to
reinitialize the map. Why do you have to
reinitialize the map? Because
each each of the ends is only getting
that map to play with.
Yeah. So, the way that that works
though, right, is that the map has a
client, right? And the client has a
render function and you just need to
know which one actually has to call
render
if you set up a Oh, I guess I see
because yeah, the key bind is
initialized at that end level. Yeah,
correct.
Correct. That's why it's a little funky.
Yeah. Okay. Well, we'll figure something
with that. But I mean, that's just stuff
for later. I mean, it's not like dire,
right?
I know. Maybe it should be client
doesn't like just connect to one M1
client. Oh, maybe.
All right. Well, this
one. Okay, let's see. Oh, this is going
to be really annoying because in Discord
you can't have two instances of yourself
in Discord. Can't have two instances.
Oh, yeah. You have two different uh
Yeah, cuz I'm on my desktop and I don't
have a mic on my desktop.
That's what you mean. You don't have a
giant boom arm that just stands in the
middle of your room. I do in my house. I
have a giant boom arm in my in my in my
house. I have one, but not at the
office. Uh, okay. What I will do, okay,
I'm just going to share my screen and
you can look at it and just type in chat
via open chat.
Okay.
Oh.
Uhhuh. That is a car going to a goal.
Why are there cars just like in the
middle of nowhere?
wiggly? Dynamics
Okay, we should fix
right? It's actually It's screwing up
occasionally because of the
wiggly Oh, the green car. Where's the
green car trying to
go? Oh, that like nearby
one. Huh.
weird. Yeah. So, this should be very
easy.
Um, we're going to have to look at the
action space and stuff and maybe like
try to drive the cars.
One more back to training. We can do one
more real quick and then we will go back
to uh looking at it. I have some
ideas. Is there a no for
steering or does it have to turn one way
or the other?
There's a
straight. Why the cars are damn wiggly
then? It should learn. If it just stops
wiggling so much, it'll do better.
It's randomly disappearing
cars. Do you see this? It's like
randomly disappearing cars.
Okay. Anything marked as expert to move
them along their
trajectory. I guess if their trajectory
ends, it just like
Okay, that's weird. Let's go back to
training then.
The cool sim
though insufficiently Tron.
All right.
All
right. Let's figure out what the hell's
wrong with this thing. Um, interesting
thing. So, round one of
the experiment I had collisions at
negative.5
[Music]
and its performance was actually a
little bit worse than the negative.75 I
just did. So I'm a little curious to
find out if I make it negative one
if I just like hyper punish it will it
start to learn faster? Maybe. I don't
know. Um, but if there's other things,
do you want me to push this right now so
that you can do stuff while Sure.
Okay. Well, I think you have to PR it
technically, right? Yeah, I'm have to PR
it to Puffer Drive. That's an easy quick
merge.
Okay. Easy merge.
How far are we off of 2K stars?
Thought we already at 2K stars. Rounded
it. We were, but we are four stars off
of 2K stars. So, if you watching this
right now, start the repo. We might hit
2K tonight.
The sea percentage will be increasing
quite a bit in this update.
mad? Send the link.
github.com/pufferai/pufferlib.
I will.
Whoops. I shall post
link. Please don't tell me I just
totally screwed myself.
Hold up. I did something dumb. What'd
you do?
I was on a detached head from
your from your fork, I guess, but not on
my own or from your repository, but not
on my own puffer drive branch.
And now I'm trying to find where my
changes just went. But I did commit
them. I just didn't push them. So I'm
trying to hunt for where the hell went.
Usually that's when you forget to add
track brand to your
folks. I think we have a decent shot of
getting this thing working tonight.
We'll see.
Yes. with my
uh GitHub skills. Don't kill me.
I'm trying to think what uh I want to do
with it because you're already running
my bigger policy.
The only things I set for grid, I said a
gamma, a lambda, I set entropy
lower, I set learning rate, and I set
mini batch size. I guess that's what
we're going to try for you.
We're also going to try to just get the
M speed to not suck.
We'll introduce you We will introduce
you to the uh the ultra settings.
today. All right, that work. Oh, sick.
It worked. All right, get cherry pick.
That's a new
one. I've never used that.
Well, I honestly
I don't know if much of my like
technical success has been because I
have like preferred simple tools over
learning complex ones or in spite of
it. I honestly don't
know. All
right. Well, I just ch I just used like
CHBT to figure out I was like, where did
my [ __ ] just go? Remember to remove the
French language path. Uh
path. Remember, just remove the uh the
French language pack.
RM-fr.
Yeah. Okay. This has all the changes.
Now, let's merge this into
your puffer
drive. Okay. All right. I just created
the
BR. Okay.
Yeah. All right. I'm going to try a run
with negative one. Oh, I also added a
punishment if you do not get to the goal
within the 91
uh time steps. You should not do that.
poor claw
cuz it's just getting punished out of
nowhere and it just doesn't know what
the hell like it's just it doesn't know
it's not counting 91 time steps.
But does that not encourage it to at
least try to do something? I don't know.
I I would try without it.
Here we go.
Well, dude, this is freaking wrong.
Look, I just loaded up the first scene
and there are two cars that are
literally like this.
No, it's because its steering is set at
Oh, okay. I thought it was a red car and
a blue car. No. So, I mean, that was
just my way for the blue car to turn red
when it collides, but I don't know if
there's a better way you want to
describe that. That's
fine. But yeah, ideally an explosion
would be good. I think I think dynamics
is a little screwy. Look at these
freaking cars.
Yeah. What?
I think those cars are marked experts
for some reason. Yeah, they're experts
that they're freaking maybe expert
disappearing act freaking Houdini here.
Yeah, they're expert Houdini cars. All
right. I mean, hey, I don't I don't know
how Whimo decided to mark these vehicles
yet.
But there's also a chance I probably
screwed something up there, but we'll
see. All right, so we're going to start
uh we're going to start messing with
some
things. Unfortunately, we can only do
copies of
M's because like the batch size changes
of the uh like the mini batch thing we
did earlier where you have a Mhm.
because I would like to have more than
75 scenes. You know, they they're good
models. They train on more than 75
scenes.
Um you know, it doesn't have to be 75,
right? It it can be like I think up to
512 I want to say, but then the batch
size increases a bunch and it's slow. So
I have to replicate that over all the
different different cores. Okay. Which
is not fun.
Well, the quickest thing to make it
faster is just to reduce the
ops. But I don't know if you want to
start with that.
You know, we'll consider it.
because you have to remember so
originally I I was only using road edges
as part of the ops but then I decided to
throw in the whole thing so that it
matches the GPU drive actual project
where they're looking at like lanes and
lines
and all the other classifications of
roads but in reality the model only
cares about road edges.
This is true. And I when I ran a test
roughly, I
mean it right now it's at the 200 obs.
And I think when I was counting my
filler
OBS, I don't remember if it was the
inverse or not, but I think it was only
I think it's like 60 to 80 of the obs
just ended up
being how I describe it like just like
filler zeros. All
right, I'm trying the negative oneative
one and
then we'll see what happens
after let's
Think how I can do
this. Hey
Ahmed. Yeah, I
do implemented Winterrad comp. I have
not heard a winner. I have not heard the
word a winrad in 10 years, but
implementing comms is good. In fact, if
you're learning basic
stuff, I would suggest checking out uh
we have a little fun library. We use
this for the demos on
puffer.ai. I wrote most of this thing. I
think Spencer, did you add I think you
added like one of these, but um I added
like I think like one or two things in
there.
Puffernet.h. This is a tiny little file
that does inference, neural net
inference that's exactly the same as
torch but in pure C. And you can load
Torch models into
simple. I'm trying to think how I want
to do this.
I think it's just
like something
times
91. 256 *
91. Not
bad. Let me see if this actually won.
96 DP horizon of 91.
works. This should be
fast if it
runs. Got to get on Neptune though.
why it's annoying that this just like
hangs
completely. Oh, it's like dead
dead. GG
terminal. I get a new terminal at some
point. I like played around like uh with
my whole setup on my laptop and I got
something I really liked and then the
freaking touchpad drivers don't work
correctly. So, I'm not
happy. I haven't been using it
much. I still think my box is screwed up
to some degree. I need to like diagnose
what's going on with it.
trains. I mean, I think next week as
well, I get all the gym equipment and I
also get my actual proper chair for
here. I'm excited
about. One of the best upgrades I
realized is swapping an office chair for
a lounge
chair. What? You just pull a lounge
chair up to your
desk. Oh, yeah. I think this is going to
be uh I think this is going to be pretty
good, Spencer.
token. I think I figured out how to fix
it. Implemented FFT direct. I'm to call
Winred want to be educational to people,
but still figuring out what's the best
way to do it. That is hard if you're not
quite experienced. It's making things
simple is much harder than doing things.
What's the guy? There is actually a guy
that did a decent enough job of this and
got a decent Twitter following out of
it. I'm trying to remember what his name
was. The guy that like made like a
pretty like decent
like
thing. All right.
Uh was in like the C
assembly community, I think.
Why does it start at point6?
Uh, that is something that's also sus.
Maybe I mean in other ones it starts at
like 0.1 so I'm not really quite certain
about that.
Well, I got the M down to 1%.
That's good. I'm sitting at 22. But but
your speed's the same speed as my speed.
260.
I mean, I'm balancing at like 260 to
290, but my GPU is kind of whack. This
is on my 4090, my local one. Okay.
But we will see if I just beat your
curve.
There's a decent chance of it with what
I just did.
I'm currently fighting at like 92% and
we'll see what
happens. What is considered advanced
topics? Best I can
do. Well, no, like literally like making
a lot of the basics simple. You know who
was the person who made like who finally
made a good CS course? It was Justin
Johnson who was my first mentor in AI
and Carpathy. Those were the first two
people who made like a good deep
learning course in 231N. So it took like
two of the best to take the base
material and actually make it simple. It
was absolute hell to learn AI like
before that off of just random YouTube
stuff and like really dense textbooks.
It sucked. and they came around and they
made it
simple. People don't get enough credit
when they make stuff simple, right?
Because you just say, "Oh, well that's
simple." It's like, "No, no, no, no. You
don't realize how hard it was before
this person worked very hard to make it
simple." It's like the stuff I do with
Puffer Lip, right? It's like, "Oh, you
have a thousand line train script,
whatever." It's like, "You wrote a
script." It's like, "No, no, no, no, no,
no. This script does everything that the
tens of thousands of lines of libraries
written in industry do. a thousand times
faster and better. And it's
simple. I like simple things, but simple
does not mean easy.
Yeah, Spencer, this run might not be too
good. We're going to see.
My run
is stalling at 92%. I This should have
been
better. Maybe we get like the slow
stable updates and we just have to up
the learning rate. I don't
know. Well, I'll tell you the thing that
I'm planning on doing next, probably in
a month or whatever, as soon as I get
this release done, my plan is to go
through like the last five years worth
of Deep Mind research and try to figure
out all the stuff that they have
discovered in like the RL schism of the
way OpenAI was doing stuff in 2019 and
then the way that DeepMind started doing
stuff and uh see which of the things
that they discovered are like more
academic versus which of them are
reasonable to implement. ment is like
general purpose RL improvements and then
integrate them all into puffer liib
ultra ultra fast. That is the next
plan. Be looking at mu0 going to be
looking at some world model stuff going
be looking at like search style stuff
going to be looking at on all their like
crazy off policy
algorithms. Yeah, mine's still stalling
at 93%. I'll just call. I'm just going
to kill it.
We're at 87 at the moment, which is not
amazing.
Take out that penalty I had um for the
91st step auto fail penalty.
What does Puffer Lib do? Is it like
PyTorch for RL? We use PyTorch, but
yeah, we try to make reinforcement
learning really, really fast and really,
really simple. And the thing is it's not
quite like PyTorch because the key thing
that's difficult about RL is you need to
run a bunch of environments really
really fast and get data from them in a
very tight loop. That is the thing
that's hard. Also your models tend to be
very small. When your models are small,
little bits of overhead matter way more.
It's like so much easier to like
optimize overhead on a language model
versus like a little tiny RLN net. thing
that's hard with language models is like
actually getting your getting your GPUs
saturated with good kernels and stuff
and then all the distributed stuff is a
nightmare. But like you know you little
bits of Python code you write on top of
that doesn't matter because the language
model's way slower in RL everything
matters.
Yeah, the whole starting at 50% score is
really sussing me out.
I don't know how that's really
occurring. It didn't happen before I
swapped this whole respawn move which
shouldn't affect anything really. I must
have
I mean that is a very large difference
right
because that that means that well
actually it could be that um if there's
some agents that are basically on top of
their goal right they're just going to
get it constantly distance is two two
meters is like what's considered and I
know that there are some goals that are
within like if two is the minimum
allowed I think there are some goals
that are sub five which is one square on
the thing. So, you just like hit forward
and you get it. Yeah, basically. Well, I
mean, that could account for it, right?
Cuz it just does that repeatedly. But,
weirdly, I didn't see that on my
original runs. Like, I just start at
0.5. Like, my [ __ ] would start at like
point
01. But maybe it was just so dumb it
just couldn't figure it out. But you
didn't see that. What? This is with the
resets, right? They're getting reset to
like a couple meters away. They get to
like get the goal like five times in an
episode.
Yeah. versus only one time at the end of
a 91st step segment. You could modify
this score metric so they still get
their reward, but the score they only
get at most once per episode if you want
to keep it consistent with the original.
Could do that. Um, but then don't I have
to change how ad log works or No, no,
just when you call it.
Well, I guess I already Okay, so I call
ad
log when they get the goal, when they
hit something, and also at the end of
the 91st step segment before
resetting because I fig the three
conditions in which the world. Yeah. So
instead of doing that basically, right,
you would just log once at 91 with did
it ever get the
goal. If you make an array of length
numbum cars, right? Got goal this
episode,
man. Yeah, I already have. Yeah, I
already have gold this episode. Or are
you just reading the code?
No, I just am guessing. Oh, no. That's
exactly what I did. I I have a length of
array with a number of cards with each
goal this episode. How to be good like
you someday. what projects or what can I
do? Tell me a bit about I mean I can do
that if you don't mind, Spencer, while I
because I'm waiting for this curve for a
bit because I'm still I'm at 90 but
we're still going
up. Also, set your plots to log if you
can't tell if they're stuck.
Um like log
x-axis. I mean I mean I've been doing
this stuff since I was like 16. Uh it
was not fun to be fair. It's easier now
to learn than it was then. It's like it
was not easy at all to learn this stuff.
And like I spent several years just
being really bad at stuff, but like
really really wanting to get better at
it and just putting a ton of effort into
learning. It was a mix of doing
projects, reading research papers,
implementing research papers, talking to
people, like studying stuff. It's like a
lot, right? It's not like an overnight
thing. Now, it's a lot easier nowadays
because they're better resources, but
then the bar is also higher for like
what's a useful contribution these days
as well. Like the stuff that I published
in my first paper would not qualify as a
paper today. Not because everybody's
gotten way smarter all of a sudden
because the resources you have now make
it a lot easier to do work than it was
to do work back then. Back then it was
like crap beta version of PyTorch or or
like TensorFlow one or heck I started on
Cafe one and uh you know whatever
Franken desktop you could rig
together. So yeah
um I have a guide on my website for
reinforcement learning specifically and
the fundamentals of that will cover
other stuff in AI. It's like if you
haven't done anything in AI, you either
do
CS231N and you actually do the
exercises or if you can't do that, you
don't have the prerequisites, then you
get the prerex, which is basically you
know what a derivative is, it doesn't
scare you to take a derivative on an
array and you are comfortable
uh with tensors, dealing with like
tensors and operations over tensors
which include which is just like
multi-dimensional arrays. That's
it. You get stuck at 91, Spencer.
Um, like give or take. I mean, I think
the furthest I ever got was 92, 93.
Well, we're still going up and it looks
it's log linear stable. In fact, it's
accelerating a little bit. Log linear
stable, it looks like.
Are you setting your x to be log?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, the company is Puffer
AI. Puffer Libs is the project. But
yeah.
Oh, all right. All right. Mine's now 92
93.
It should be faster than this to be
fair. We'll see what happens if it
breaks into 93 94
land. If it gets there,
I mean, this is a good log linear graph,
I will say. so
far. Now, why is it log linear? Like,
why does it take this long? I don't
know. Could be
hypers, could be obs. Could be a mix of
the both,
right? I mean, do you really think that
like I mean, what are you at like 100
million steps right now? 200.
Uh, what' you say? I'm at 200.
I think it took them how many steps?
Like 500 million.
I think that's for more m
though. Wrong foundation. I think next
step is doing a paper. Send your website
link. It's puffer.ai.
They're at like well yes they are doing
way more so to be I don't know if that's
easier. I think it was harder generally
or it was it was more stable. It's for
sure has to be more stable because if
you have like a really whack map in one
of them that you only have one of the
distribution of it like if you have a
U-turn map in your 75
be weird.
They got to 97% by 500 million and then
by the time you got to like a billion
they're in like the high 98s to 99s.
I think that I I forget what it was that
I got there. It was like 23 seconds or
something that I got like their thing to
solve
in. It was like for only a few maps or
whatever, but still.
Oh, hey. Oh, I'm at 94 now. It's
climbing.
95. Did you set it to run for longer?
I'm at 150 million or 140. Oh, you're
doing better than than I am here. H I
took out the penalty that was um the you
get punched in the face if you do
nothing for 91. Damn it. I Yeah. Where
do I Where do I take that out? Where can
you commit it?
You just want to do it. I mean, it's
good. Oh, yeah. Fork. Okay.
Kind of an ordeal for me to make a PR
for like a two. Yeah. I forgot. I forgot
that you had to do that [ __ ] Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. All right. Go to line like I
think 1057 or around there. Top of cep.
What is it in theh file? Go around to
the top of cstep. It's what? It's
there's a if conditional that says if
not reached goal this episode and then
you have rewards minus one and end
episode reward. Yeah, that those two
lines. Delete those.
Do you want to set this score to zero?
Is this correct?
Um, I do. It's probably redundant, but
Okay. What was it getting before you did
that?
Before I made this change, it peaked at
like 91 92.
So, that's what I'm seeing here. It
spiked to like 93 randomly one time.
If you link to GitHub real quick, I'll
take a quick look at code.
Now I'm hovering at like 94 95. Okay,
we'll see. I will say I did get a very
nice log linear. So what I did for
reference, the thing that I did uh I
changed it to just under like
8192 m. So I I took it down to 64 maps
and uh I upped it to 16 workers. You get
a total of like 8192. So M goes to 1%.
And uh I set the BPT or I set the
horizon and the batch size to match 91
exactly.
So you're training on mini batches of
full
rollouts. Oh, that's
clever. All right. All right. I'm like
getting a little bit stuck, but I'm at
95%.
It did kind of well it evened out at the
end but then also cosign and kneeling is
jank.
Let me let me link you the one the
current run I'm going
after built this we retrain with your
new changes and we see if the punch and
face reward not punching face reward is
better.
All right. I just linked you my current
run that's doing seemingly better than
the other runs.
I'll do that.
But it does look like it's whole it's
kind of getting stuck now at 95.
95 is better than you've seen, right? 95
is definitely better than I've seen
without a question.
So, as I said, you fixed the dumb asking
thing. Yeah. Yeah. I to be fair though I
think probably it is getting a little
inflated by like the easy the easy quick
it is. So but at the same time don't
forget some of this the collisions that
are happening right here could 100% be
because by the time one car gets to its
spot respawns another car could be
passing through that exact point. True.
Totally true.
There is some amount of upper bound due
to that problem. Now, as to what it is
statistically, I have no not a single
280. My off-road rate is now at a pretty
good situation. It's less than 1%.
which means it's fully deter learned
that don't hit a curb.
Does it reset on off-road or no? Yes, it
does
both off-road and
collision. It resets.
We could just see if this changes the
curve at all.
My curve is just a is basically just on
top of the other
curves. It just sits neatly on top. You
want to see how clean this uh this train
curve looks though? Even though it's not
like perfect, but you want to see how
clean this thing looks now.
All right. Look at
this self-driving. Yeah. So, this is an
N. Uh, so this is based on an N by NYU,
which is a GPU accelerated driving sim.
Spencer here ported it to Puffer Lib on
CPU and made it faster. So now we have
our own uh our own sim that's like
really fast that we can run tons of
experiments on. So we're trying to
basically make uh a better version of
NYU's sim so that they can use it for
their research. We can do cool stuff
with it in Puffer Lib and everyone's
happy. All right. My my thing just
stopped at
96%. It spiked at the last second to get
like a lucky run.
Well, it can't spike at the end because
um so that the last section if you look
there should be like an extra data point
at the end
and that is from we do like a full eval
or like we do a longer eval at the end.
So the last metric should not be the
lucky one. It's actually the more
accurate one.
the one at like the one B reports at the
very end,
you should see like a flat line or
whatever, like a flat line segment at
the end. So that flat line segment, all
those steps in there are compressed into
that last data point.
This is an intentional thing with Puffer
so that we get accurate evals. All
right. Well, I'm going to download this
model and see how it
eval. You see, let's show off the
self-driving
sim a little bit for a stream. So, this
is it. Now, the these cars aren't doing
anything. We're going to have to load in
a policy to see them do anything. But,
uh yeah, you know, you can load in
actual real world maps selected. I think
Wayimo data set. If you um hold like
it's going to be press tab one time to
switch to a different car.
Yeah. Yeah. If you hold Yeah. If you
hold control, it puts it in that mode.
And if you hold if you hold shift
um you you can use the arrow keys. So if
you use the arrow keys, it'll increment
your acceleration or your um steering by
one just based off the index of its
position. So if you go to like
acceleration, okay, well that's going to
really hurt your brain. But what is
this?
Uh you're going in a circle right now
because you're steering. So go on the
press right arrow a few times so you get
your steering to around
six and once you get to a steering of
six should be going in a straight fine.
This is uh probably a bad time to
mention. Uh I actually don't have a
driver's license. And uh you can see
right here probably
[Laughter]
why no F1 puffer.
Well, we can do it in simulation. Is
this your fulltime? Yeah. Puffer AI is a
company. All our software is free and
open source, but like we do really
really good high performance RL. So
companies that want us to help their RL
headaches go help make their RL
headaches go away can pay us for
priority service extended support and
things like that around all our tools.
All right, let's see how the policy
looks. Uh the policy is to drive the
cars. We just don't have one loaded into
the version that I just showed you. We
are training the policy to try to make a
good driving policy right now and we are
trying to figure out why it's not like
perfectly solving the env because like
usually we uh most we do really really
well on. So we have some still like this
is a new env and there's still some bugs
left in it most
likely. Uh my not punch and face reward
does not seem to be doing quite as well
though maybe it changes.
Uh, I guess it caught back up. It had
this like weird dip in it.
Oh, my email does not look very good.
Weirdly,
the um all our demos are on here. We got
like lots of game M. We got other
stuff. Neural MMO
3. Big
MMO. You have like classic arcade style.
Simple. It's so weird.
This one's kind of fun to watch. This
one's also by
Spencer and Fear.
You're sure this is supposed to be doing
better, right, Spencer? I mean, mine
turned out better, but weirdly enough,
in Eval, it didn't turn out
better. In Eval, it's a little jank.
That's
weird. I'm waiting to see if this
actually does anything different on
convergence. Hope you make
it. I mean, I'm doing just fine here,
right? Like I like I'm doing this
instead of taking like a company job at
the moment because like we're actually
making RL ludicrously better in very
little amount of time. Like based on
where Puffer is now and where the whole
field of RL was a year ago, it's night
and day. Like we're solving problems out
of the box that it would have taken like
months and like several people
um just a year
ago and we also have a few clients. So
like you know we're doing okay. Ultimate
goal here is to just make RL sane and
stable. Just make this a mature
technology basically. While is really
really powerful was solving Dota in 2019
beating top frozen starcraft go. It's
also been used in like driving. It's
been used in nuclear nuclear fusion.
It's been used in what the heck else,
drones, uh, superhuman drone piling,
lots lots of different things. And, uh,
the problem is every single one of these
takes like 20 a 20 person team in like a
year or two to do anything. So, we are
trying to make it sane, stable, actually
a usable technology almost out of the
box. And, uh, we're making good
progress. We're definitely making good
progress.
We do a combination of engineering
really high performance sims, algorithm
development on top of those really high
performance sims. So we can just run
thousands and thousands of
experiments, do a bunch of
stuff and advice depends on your goals,
right? Depends what you're trying to do.
Can be very very different if you're
like just trying to learn the stuff.
You're trying to go to grad school,
you're trying to get a job, trying to
start your own company. It's like very
different.
Yeah. I mean, Minecraft turned out like
a little bit better on top. Like it it
definitely is sitting on top of the
other one. This one is like snaking back
and forth on top of the previous
one. And I have some stable graphs.
It seems like it it's having a hard time
figuring out that when it is starting at
a stationary position that it needs to
have a continuous acceleration going
like positive because when I was looking
at its actions
as um in Eval it's like rapidly flying
back and forth on numbers. So it just
effectively was sitting still because it
wasn't going actually fast like deciding
that it needed to go faster.
It could be that it just decided screw
it. I I'm hitting too many obstacles and
I no longer want to deal with it. Yeah.
I mean, that's what that the NYU team
talked about a lot in their in their
paper was
that if you don't have a high enough
entry coefficient, they said that like
what tends to happen is you just decide
to sit like a turtle and do
nothing because it can't ever find the
reward. But, I mean, at 96, I feel like
it should be doing
better. All right. Well, you could try
decreasing the collision uh the
collision penalty.
Yeah, try that. It was weird. At zero,
it did nothing. But maybe if it's really
small.
Well, yeah. Zero. It's not
If there's no collision penalty, then
yeah.
What if I do like negative0.1?
That's try negative0.25.
I've done five already and that would
create a worse policy than 75 and 0.1.
Really?
Huh? Yeah, that was a little funky.
Weird. But we'll try. See what happens.
I mean, arguably at this point, it's
sweepable now. Yeah, it is arguably
sweepable. I did technically just fix
sweeps.
I think they're not broken in this dev
branch either.
Maybe I'm still sus out about the whole
score starting at 0.5, but I don't see
any reason
why there is like a bug on that at the
moment. Applied scientist at Google
Brain. Google Brain have applied
scientists. I guess they do. Yeah, I
have no idea. Experted deep learning,
specifically CV. I want to make better
models.
Yeah, time to start getting deep into
research then,
right? I mean, most researchers just get
very very familiar with an area, right?
They've read all the important papers in
an area, develop a very strong intuition
about what directions matter, what
directions
don't. And that just comes from having
done a lot of research and then like
getting a gauge on what types of
directions are viable. also like what
papers and like what types of papers the
results actually are correct and
replicate, which ones
don't, how to check that type of stuff
without spending
months. I spent some time in
CB. I did a few cool things.
I actually are the applied teams usually
PhD wreck or a master's
wreck? I forget.
What is the implementation of comp 2D?
See, like that's like an odd question,
right? because it's the PyTorch default
and like you basically would never even
ask that unless
um unless you specifically work on like
low-level model
optimization, right?
Oh, I thought you were talking about
something completely different. There's
a much older winter grad than this.
How many time steps are you going?
You're going 250. Yeah, this did not
help. It was like on par, but it did
not. It's 92.
Okay, so it's
fine. I mean, I was the one who told you
that it probably would, so my bad.
Well, it worked on mine,
but I don't know why not yours. I mean,
maybe I just got lucky. Who knows? I
mean,
there can be runs of luck. I'm pretty
sure luck can exist.
As you show, yeah, the C++ code is
inference only. That's highly
unoptimized. The point is it's simple.
But like we use this to load small
neural networks onto our web page for
demos. like the neural nets on the web
page that you see those are running live
in your browser
sent you a link of just my my in general
wann I don't know if it has the ones
visualized that I do but if you look
like the top like five that are
visualized you can see which ones from
orange to purple
indicate the lowest to highest
penalty in order of pretty much
performance. So more penalty is more
score. Interesting.
At the moment. Well, it looks like
orange may break that theory possibly,
but hard to say.
What you think it's just going to cross
through them? I don't know. Maybe. Maybe
I don't. I don't know.
Either that or it'll stall out like the
one at.5, the dark gray one or light
gray
one. Why is it that no matter what I do,
the curve stays on top of other
Are you convinced that the learning rate
has to be at 0.05 start?
No, not at all. Oh.
Ha. See, did I get something?
Oh, it's diverging. Divergence.
out. Oh, orange is crossing through
gray. There's hope in
society. Oh, no. No. It hit a wall. God
damn
it. So, uh, check this graph out. This
looks pretty cool. Oh, yo, that's doing
things. Mhm.
What wizardry did you put on that
one? I said, gam.
[Laughter]
Yeah, it's like one of those just shut
up and run a sweep moments, right?
Well, I mean, it's like it seemed like
the gam would have been too high, right?
It's like only a 91st step horizon.
And based on my sweep, that would tend
to say from what I talked about earlier,
it uh it was in like the N91 to 0.987
range. I want to see if this gets hard
stuck at 0.92 again though. Yeah, that's
fair. I might get hard stuck again. I
want to see if this is
like this is also just like happens to
get stuck in the exact same spot.
Did you put back the punch in the face
penalty or No, no, I just left it. Okay.
No punch in face. No punch in face.
Okay. I mean, that's a way heck of a
faster convergence right there. No. Way
way faster. That's what I'd expect,
right? Like 40 50 mil and it just works.
currently solving driving faster than
breakout.
Speaking of which, we do have sweeps
going for
that. Is there a breakout sweep? Yeah,
breakout sweep.
sweeps. 23 24 seconds so far is our
best.
Damn, we're sub 30. Oh
yeah. Buffer very fast, dude. Rest in
peace when I first was getting runs at
like five minutes.
I mean, so Breakout can train at like
3.5 million steps per second now fast
settings. So
fair enough. I kind of did some
optimization.
Bro was playing unfair. Understood.
Yeah, I put some work
in. All right, so I mean we're at 93.
All
right. Mine capped at 96.
What did you do to get 96?
Um, I don't know. Pray. Did you change
the rewards?
No. All I did was do the no faith.
Why did it not help me at all?
Okay, I'm going toile I'm going to
recompile again. And if I see it not
copy, it copied. See? No recompile.
All right. I see. I see. So, unless I
did it wrong.
I don't think so. This is correct. All
right. This is all you did. You took
this stuff out. Yeah. That's what mine
That's what mine looks like.
I don't know how yours mattered and mine
didn't. I'm at 94 though.
Yeah.
The.25 is currently at 89% but
struggling.
Oh, you're 94. Mhm.
Having that thing there is very
nice. Oh, I don't know. My other one
that got 95 better one. You're 95 now.
Um, I set in order to get to 96 my
reward penalt or my penalties to be at
negative one and I think maybe at
negative.5 or 75 75.
Yeah. So, we'll try that.
You said you got you put gamma at 98.
Mhm.
Okay. Try that online.
I have done 60 pull-ups today that I
would have not had done otherwise if I
had not had that thing right there. All
right, let's see what happens. Gamma
98, I guess. Wait, you took out GA,
right? Or no? No. No.
Well, kind of. We replaced
it with puffer advantage.
But is it still is the GE lambda still
being used in puffer advantage or not?
Yes.
Okay.
It is just um puffer advantage is
strictly J plus V trace.
Think I have to do some literature. I
don't know what V trace is. Well, it's
supposed to be off policy correction,
but from my experiments, it doesn't
actually work the way it's advertised.
It works, but not at all for the reasons
advertised so far as I've seen.
Did you fix the uh fixed time step sweep
bug? Time step sweep bug. I don't know
if I fixed it in the death branch. It is
fixed in release.
Oh, whoa. I'm at already at 90%. What
just happened?
Yeah, it trains really fast with
uh the setting I gave you.
Did yours cap out or are you still
going? 96.
It looks like it's still going. You got
to set the Look, you do
this log linear.
No, I get that. I feel like even with
that
with a very smooth learning curve. That
is comparable now
um to them at 500. They they had uh
well, I think that we have uh we'd have
to make it like one completion per
episode or
whatever, but solved is still going to
be solved in either case.
PF trying to think what we do next.
I would eval the policy that you're
going to fit which this one if you can
that can be
done because I'm a little
5 percentage collision rate makes sense,
right? It should be roughly one minus
the uh
What's DNF rate?
Do not did not finish rate. Yeah, but is
it it didn't finish just in the last
like since it respawned last or is like
ever in the 91? It should be. It has
never finished in the 91 steps nor did
it collide with anything.
which effectively means it's the rate at
which it does nothing. So, can you add a
thing that's just like the did finish at
least once
rate like completion rate or whatever?
Can you add because like then we would
actually be able to still compare to
their curves.
Well, I think that's what score is. No,
because it can get multiple it can get
multiple scores per 91
steps. You see,
you see that's what I was trying to say.
Well, you but you add multiple logs per
91 steps, right? Every time it gets the
goal, if it gets the goal in two, if it
gets the goal in two steps, you're going
to add it like 40 some odd times.
Yes, I would. Yeah. So, you got like I
would make a completion rate thing.
96.5. That's helpful. Mine's
at
94. I feel like the Neptune curves are
cleaner than 1B curves, like based on
the how quickly it reports.
How quickly it reports. Yeah, because my
curves are all spiky. Oh, no. That's
that's because of my batch size.
And I really hope that eval will. I'm
going be really happy if it does.
Oh, give it a minute. Then we just got
to get it to 99.
Yeah, it's the easiest part, right?
Yeah, it's the easiest part. To be fair,
we It's probably just to shut up and
sweep it kind of a
thing. Probably worth trying to like PR
this onto the latest release branch just
so we can like use the fixes in there
and like run a proper sweep.
Um, yeah, I'm fine with that. It
shouldn't really be any different. Like,
I didn't mess with that stuff.
Well, I don't know what the difference
is
between. You may want to pull release
into whatever puffer drive branch this
is. Well, I'm at 96 now, too. But it's
bouncing between six and
five.
Has yours gone to 97 at all or no?
Finally, we do want a completion rate
would be
nice. Um, I'll add that right now and
then ship it to you.
Arguably it should just happen at the
reached goal this
episode like did it happen? Are you
saying like as long as it happens one
time, right?
Yes, it should if it it should be if it
happens one time. But that can still be
lower than the score
variable. It can be lower or higher than
the score variable.
Okay. 96.4 is the final
evaluation. Okay.
Uh, the blue car goes near this first
goal and sits there.
I think its goal is further away, too.
Why is the green car just like it gets
close to the goal and sits there?
That seem weird.
Yes.
Do we see if it's getting reward for
doing this? It's getting reward.
Uh if you wanted to spy if it itself was
just getting
There are four green dots. Are these
yellow cars
also? Oh, look. Cuz see this see this
yellow car right here just like getting
its goal repeatedly. Yeah. And then this
one's also getting to its goal. And then
the green car is like not for some
reason.
The yellow car in front of it is also
not.
Mhm. I question how that's 96%. It's
because of this
Masks should be off. I I pretty sure I
deleted everything, but you can double
check that.
Fine. All right, I'm putting in a
completion rate.
kernels. So far, let's see. If I only
put the completion rate to be set at the
reached goal this episode within the 91
time step, I would believe that that is
accurate.
If you set completion rate be like did
it at all during those 91 time steps
ever reach its
goal because I have a variable that's
reached goal this episode. Right. Yeah.
I set that to one if that agent hits its
goal. Yeah. And if I check that only one
time at the very end of the 91 steps
that should be the completion rate.
Right. It depends when you add log. It
depends when you add log. So every time
you add a log in, right, that's like
recording a trial. So you can add log
when you can only really add
log once per agent after hitting 91
steps.
I can't add log multiple times prior to
that.
Uh, no, not really.
Okay. Well, I made it I made training
really slow. I succeeded in doing that.
Wait, but then why would I need a
completion rate if I have if score is
effectively completion rate if you only
call ad log at the end of the end of the
91 steps?
Why would you need score? You mean? No.
Wouldn't completion rate be score if you
if you move the ad logs on collision and
reaching the goal?
Yes.
Okay. So, I just got to take out the
extra logs then.
Correct.
I just want to see if this does
anything.
Also, my latest run said 98.2.
What did you do?
Um, I
had one collision penalty. Okay, I
didn't try that yet to be fair.
And I had gamma
98. And I don't remember if I had g if I
had my GE chains in there or not, but
we'll find out again here in a second.
I'm going to recompile with the uh with
score should now be effectively the
completion rate because I took out the
ad logs um whenever you reach the goal
and whenever you collide.
All right, let's see what
happens. Fingers
right. Now score starts at like 0.04.
Good. Which makes more sense.
Yeah. This is probably going to make it
harder
because All right. That was super sus.
Mhm.
Well, now I wonder what the actual
completion rate is
like where we nowhere near 90% at all.
It was just hyper leaning because it was
hitting like one goal like 50 times in
one single event. Quite probably.
I wanted that checked.
I just want to see if these two graphs
diverge at
like Yeah, this is looking not too hot
at the moment.
happens. Interestingly, making the uh
the input dim much larger doesn't seem
to help.
Yeah, we may have been a little too
excited when the tour was like
The whole obace is floats, right?
The whole obace is what? Floats. Yes.
Well, there is a little bit of a one
hots at one point, but it should be like
a float one.
welcome. Set your policy to be the
default policy.
You think you uh do you think you beat
the default policy?
You'd hope so, right?
I would. Yeah.
I don't know. Let's see. The speed would
has to be like way faster though, right?
I don't know. Let's see.
It would have to be. It's flat. There's
no way it's not. Well, I'm adding with
the LSTM.
No, flat is going to be at like 800k.
I'm
sorry. I don't know. you're going to
have a gigantic hidden like gigantic
input layer
because when before I ever did any of
the it probably still policy stuff I was
at like 900k to a million steps per
second at one point
which is funny because lops wise it
should be better with the max pool
policy
also I'm at like 7% after 80 million
steps by the
now. Oh, I think it's just
slow. Or maybe it's compiling kernels
forever. I don't know.
What would be something? I mean, I
add Okay.
is like the backward pass mini batch
size just freaking ridiculous now or
something.
I don't know why it just like isn't
starting
now. That's kind of a weird
thing. All right. What it would be I did
weird. I
mean, there may technically be an int
somewhere in the
OBS. I don't know if it's cast to a
float, but I don't know if that should
be a preventative thing.
I don't know why it would hang.
What was it doing where it was hanging
before and like we had to like figure
something out?
Uh, it was the wrong dash size. Like the
numbers the the puffer advantage was
tripping
out. So
weird. Doesn't even get into the
evaluate.
Yeah, it doesn't get past um async
reset.
How does it not work with
uh That's kind of bizarre,
right? That default doesn't work.
Yeah, mine hasn't learned like anything
after I switched the ad log, so that's a
little
concerning.
Something's wrong
then. Is it Are you sure that it's not
like it's only logging the ones that
finish exactly on 91 time steps or some
[ __ ] That's what I'm wondering.
I think it's a matter of me doing
something stupid here. Just try and fix
it.
If I only touch score one time and it's
after that
here. How do I turn all this print
garbage off?
from? It's like coming from everywhere.
I totally get rid of this [ __ ]
man. Like this is I think they're in a
nets mostly.
right. Well, now my score starts at like
02.
Hey,
bet. Yeah, we're coding.
How does this still not freaking I guess
it's in the Syon.
All right, we need to cure we need we
need to cure you of like the need to
freaking print everything everywhere.
Okay. But printing here may have been
necessary for a little bit because of
the
whole making sure that the binary file
copied
properly. That isn't that shouldn't even
be a but that's not even a thing with
the Syon. The Syon should be fine. It's
the new built system that does that
[ __ ] So you merged I merged some
things. I don't know. Ah, input size.
There's our actual
error. So, yeah, it was just eating the
error message pretty much. So, what you
were doing actually is it would print
the error message and then it would
finish flushing the crazy buffer from C.
Solid. That feels like a skill right
there.
I will have to head out to eat dinner in
like 15 20 minutes. Cool.
I will get the uh documents in place and
then I will go to bed.
Oh, I will send that to you tonight.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay, I think maybe now the ad log is in
the right place
afterwards.
What? Or is going up slowly and not just
like failing good? Yeah,
it's still taking a while though. It's
like at 29 right now, but it's at least
at least it started at like zero. It
like started at 20% then dropped down to
like 14 which is I don't think that
unreasonable because there are some
things that are pretty
close and now it's trying trying to
brain but we're not fixing Gork plays
Pokemon after we are
fixing me going to
sleep. I've
done four 1 kilometer hard intervals.
I've done 60 pull-ups today. And I've
done 10 hours of streaming. I am
tired. Okay. It does train at 485k steps
per second.
Okay. You got default going with 55%
copy overhead.
overhead. Oh, and the curve is above the
main
is. How funny is it going to be if the
default model's just
better? I'm not going to put it in
impossible because the entire time I
used the default model, I had the
relative uh goal bug.
We are at 93. But don't forget that 93
is like not a real 93. Well, why don't
you actually get a real number then?
Because the eight is 8% is also not a
real number.
Okay. I'm at like 35 right now. All
right. Could be a real number. You know,
it's training on the same thing, though.
Yeah. I mean, it's not like anything has
changed in the actual training. It just
changed what's reporting. Yep.
Why isn't it real 93? We got some log
shenanigans going on.
All right. I hit you with the latest run
that's going on right now. I need to
take You're welcome to take a crack at
it, Bet, but
uh I don't know.
fixing
things. Let me get some more followers
first on Grock plays Pokemon.
Can we get that guy to just like go run
uh run the thing on Pokemon Blue real
quick so we can say like, "Hey, also if
we beat both games, do you beat both
games?" It would be
40%. I honestly don't know what would be
more stressful in that guy's life. like
literally being on Grock or on X 24/7 or
running six companies. It's like that's
kind of a toss up in my
book. Uh we are at 95% with the default
policy.
wise. I thought it should be better
because max pooling is an expensive
operation.
Why would max be an expensive operation?
I thought we talked about it last time
of like when you're having to call the
max operation on top of
uh you now
have the first network of your input and
then you're running through another
layer. So you now have that was a
different that was a totally different
context though for that.
So it's if you do if you run the full
size layer on each and then you max pull
then yeah but it's supposed to be like a
small layer then max pull and then the
bigger
layer. Got to count your
So yeah, this uh default policy
literally does the same
thing and is faster. There.
All right, I'm now getting stuck at like
43%.
I mean that's more
reasonable like to what we saw in the
results and that
would so actually here's the
thing the fact that I'm literally doing
just as well if not better with the
default policy you think that the data
is like in the correct order in the
other policy
Okay. Right. I would generally hope so,
but I mean default policy is doing
better. Literally feeding the data in a
flat is doing better.
I mean, every time I've checked it's
fine, but because one time I would like
I actually change the observation just
to be like a random number of the first
observation of each like road and
partner.
And the indexing seemed totally fine,
but I mean I could be doing something
funky.
For sure. I think that whatever we have
currently on that log shenanigan is
definitely not real. Yeah.
Is it It's float 32 the whole thing,
right?
I don't have float 64 anywhere. Well,
yeah. Like the the observer are float
32s though.
Yes. Is there anything we we Is there
stuff we can get rid of or is it just
It's got to be that ridiculously big.
you can realistically draw probably 50%
of the
odds. Thank you for listing the entire
possible space of the program
bet. Most most
helpful. You're the LLM.
I am not an
LLM. I don't know if I'm as dumb as just
like shoot me or something. I don't
It would require me to do some some
jerryrigging a little bit back to what I
did before, but well, we'll wait for a
bit on that then. Do you want me
to make a PR for what I think the
correct ad log situation is here, or do
you want to do that yourself right now?
Well, if it's like substantial, then
yeah, make a PR for the log.
Okay.
I would say substantial, but it's like
eight lines or whatever. Uh, that's a
lot of typing.
is I'm trying to think what else in
here.
It's weird when we're RLing everything
else so well to have this thing not, you
know, I do want to do another round of
hyper pram tuning on everything just to
see. And I actually I have some stuff
going on that now.
All right, I just made the PR to go into
the puffer drive.
Puffer puffer driving simulator.
I think it's get stash pop the single
file
Uh, it looks like there's some jank
command as
whatever.
Put it in the
chat. If you do get stash list, you can
find out which thing in your stash
wasn't part of something and then you do
the
file. That's entire Those aren't [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this. Did the pole wipe your config? It
shouldn't have. Yeah. Well, I have it in
stash, but
Yeah, that's my bad. Let me uh let me
delete those prints right
now. Why is it numb agents is
64? Oh, total
size
23 296.
Okay, I think this is everything. 16
workers, 16
M's exercise eight.
2 that
good. That's what mine
was. That's what I believe should be now
correct. If you go and you look at step
That should be correct because reached
goal this episode
is the only thing that allows for ad log
to be uh is the only place that score
gets
This does not seem to do particularly
well now, does it? Oh, it's just died as
sus. So, I applied my settings and it
just no longer
alerts. Yours didn't just dip, did it?
Mine dipped and then went up.
Okay, so we'll leave it be for a bit. It
dipped for like I don't know a minute
and then started climbing and then mine
peaked at like point4.
And that is generally consistent with
the training pattern I've had in the
past was a dip and then it then and then
a rise.
Probably just learning to not run into
walls or
whatever. All right, I'm going to switch
you to mobile. I'm going to start to
pack
Oh, are the boxes with you now in the
new facility or are they back in
Florida? Only one of them's here.
Okay.
Yep. Yeah. As soon as tariffs are out,
hopefully we just get a whole bunch of
boxes. Be good.
I mean, the fact that this is at least
going up means we can probably sweep it
to see how much is in the
hypers. And then from
there, the thing that's annoying is that
the hyper prim sweep is not in the best
spot at the moment.
So, if we get this into the release
branch and my other hyper pram sweeps
are good, then what we can do from that
probably. See, are they any
good the first
run? Hang
on. Oh, no. Okay, that's good. Yeah, we
are getting stuff.
Uh, no. It's I'm looking at this is this
is a totally different thing. This is
hyper pram sweeps for uh mazes. Um Oh,
nice. But yeah, this looks like our
hyper pram sweeps at least doing
something reasonable. Like if you get
this into the release branch, we can run
that hyper pram sweep on it and then
that should at least tell us if there's
like some alpha left in this
thing,
right? Yeah, that would be good. And
then like and then we'll know if it's
the hypers or not. And then uh it's
probably going to be like data problem.
It's like always data problem.
Okay.
And we can So is the release branch just
called like release right now or? Yes.
Okay. It's you're going to see like I've
it's I've done crazy things with it, but
none of it should make it particularly
difficult to do anything with the M's.
Um, I'm just like doing tons of things
trying to get it ready for the
release. Look how few files we have in
here. Oops. This is in
20 and this is in release. I guess we
still have a bunch. It's fewer
though. Like minus
five. Okay. I can't do anything about
all the cuda and stuff.
Okay, then. Okay, I'll try and get it
into
release. I presume whatever you have in
config is like not that relevant at the
moment or um I mean I don't know you
want this
if you want it just dunk it in there. I
mean, I could or you just want to put in
the general chat. Either way, you can do
that either
way. That's what I did. So, I I mapped
it so that it would be aligned with the
uh episode
bounds. Let's see what your current one
is doing.
379. So yeah, it looks like it'll get
stuck in the point fours most likely.
That's where mine got stuck at. I don't
know. It depends what the slope is. Hard
to say.
A number of people do this, including
P-Dubs, like the creator of the Pokemon
stuff originally. His artificial life
sims are cool. I don't really know if
there's anything to do with RL in them,
but they're cool.
and I'll get that thing signed to you in
the morning. Yep. So, I Yeah, that'll be
good. So, I will send that stuff over
and then I think that the goal for the
GPU drive stuff. The best thing we can
do is just get into release so that we
can like keep running stuff as we get
closer to release. We'll do a full
sweep, right? We can easily set up a
full sweep. Once we have that, you'll
have access to all the latest stuff on
it way more easily. And
um it's probably a data problem is my
guess. Yeah. Like I don't see how it
wouldn't be. It's not that hard of a
problem.
It's not that hard of a learning problem
compared to other stuff. I mean, heck,
even the maze solving should be harder
than this, right?
Yeah. I mean, I I even think that the
tower climb environment should be
harder. I mean,
and we're just like we're in space like
Yeah.
I mean, a sequential movement. Yeah.
There has to be something. Yeah. So, I'm
certain I'm going to be really pissed
off if when we do find it, though. We
should figure out how to get more of
these things loaded in as well. Um, more
of these maps loaded in. You know, like
Spencer, it could literally just be as
simple as like you pick a number of
agents and then you load maps until you
hit that number and you toss the ones
that are go over
it. Like, it could be as easy as that.
And then we could randomize the maps. Do
we get actually good domain
randomization? That's like trivial,
right?
Yeah, but you're gonna miss out on
certain maps. No. Or are you going to
just try and get it always under your
optimal number because not every map
combo is going to get you to Yeah, just
under like o over either way. So like we
specify, let's say we want 512 uh cars
per worker. So five like per core. We
just make maps until we have 512 of
them. And like they don't have to be the
first end maps anymore either. You just
pick whatever ones until you get to 512
total agents. Let's say you get to 520
agents, you overshoot. You just drop the
last eight. You don't give them actions
or
anything. Is the dropping part weird?
Like how does inside of the actual code?
No, you just don't give them actions or
you just
I mean it'll muck up the the solve score
by 1%.
Yeah, cuz like what if you your last map
and you're as you're say you're at 511,
right? Then your last map will only have
like one agent that is actively getting
there. Would that
not screw with that? No, it'll just
screw with the logs for that one map.
Okay. Which I guess arguably across the
512, however many maps it ends up being
from should be a fairly small. Well,
it's not trivial because the thing is
you'll get stuck at like 99% instead of
99.9 or whatever. And that actually is a
distinction that matters. Well, I think
we should do something like that because
training on the same 75 maps and like
replicated across 16 cores is not good.
Yeah. I mean, ideally, we need to be
able to make it so it's across 10,000
maps to get it to be comparable. Well,
but then we have to have we have to fix
the shape errors, right? Like because
the shapes have to match.
Yeah, they did map resampling.
I don't even know if they needed to do
that, but yeah.
I think they they changed maps every
like couple hundred million steps. I
remember how annoyingly slow that code
was.
It was like 20 mil or 40 mil or
something. I think
it it was it was some fixed number. I
don't remember what it was, but it's
some fixed number that they did that. I
don't know if that's what we're going to
do, though. We get 40 uh 43% by the way.
Okay. So that's our starting point pre-
sweep.
Still not very great.
No, but hey, at least now it's not going
to be a total pain with all the CUDA
kernels and stuff because like because
it like we now have reasonably shaped
data.
True. True. And I think with that other
change, it's going to be even easier.
the the map changes you're talking about
the random one or
cool it is just about 9 so I'm going to
call it here and uh yeah we can chat
tomorrow whenever you're around
okay that works now thanks yeah
man
okay so for stream folks thank you for
tuning
And we'll be back with more dev tomorrow
in the
morning. Uh, all my stuff is at
puffer.ai. This is all open source
code. You want to help me out? Free star
the repo. We're only a few stars off of
2000. Currently rounded up from 1990
something, but almost at 2K
proper. If you want to get involved with
development, join the Discord. Most of
our top contributors came in with zero
RL
experience. So join that if you want to
get involved and learn some RL or if you
already have RL experience and you want
to help contribute to the
research. Other than that, you can
follow me on X for more RL
content. Post articles you can't find
anywhere else. Thank you and I will be
back in the morning. Night.